[Music]
don't
you want me hey babe
don't you want me hello
hey baby hey babe how you doing we have
our guest Laura Compton hello how are
you babe I welcome to California yes so
ghetto how um but you're not from
Compton it's so hard to see your eyes
thank you we uh
I I needed to blur my vision for this
podcast
we dressed up today because we knew that
you would be elevated and dressed you
look amazing and we were we felt yeah we
felt a little bit like you know what
normally we just schlep in but I wanted
to look up I wanted to look nice you
look fantastic thank you yeah I feel I
feel a little self-conscious that I'm
wearing shorts and a t-shirt but I
because you have a cocktail party Vibe
going on oh I just wanted to wear
something casual is this casual yeah
really just comfortable you know it's a
lot of bad throw myself together you
ever see a naked bun where he's like I'm
gonna slip into something more
comfortable yeah he takes over soon
um Laura has a great podcast called
first date with Laura Compton Lauren and
Lauren that's what I said I I uh would
you take it would he be a good first
date absolutely not that would be a red
flag yes I think listen for me I think I
am a good first date yeah I think well
I'm a fun facts guy I think I know I
could come to a first date with a lot of
fun facts probably one or two of my
children and I think that I think that I
I've read a lot I read a lot that's good
quality on a first day it's like you
just remembered that yes yes it's also
it's also a lie
um no I do read a lot you read so much I
read every you're ready for myself
questions on Instagram no I yes he's
very well read for real I read I read
every morning I not this morning you
were literally going through the
bookshelf going through the authors and
what they're like yes yeah but but you
when you got me and Sal hung out last
night and we got like next level drunk
yeah got drunk and high we drinking red
wine we had a pizza party and we had a
good time right kids
kids were there fell asleep girls it was
great we but I normally I try to wake up
for my children wake up at 5am and I try
to read do my reading and writing at 5am
to read is insane but I couldn't I
couldn't today today I woke up eight
o'clock full junkie piece of didn't
read a goddamn thing okay I didn't read
a goddamn thing but on a first date I
would be prepared I would come in I
would come in I think with something to
say I'd have a quote or something lined
up and try to wiggle it in there to try
to come so that's why you kill on a
first date I try to get prepared with
quote I'd come in with prepared
yeah
right that's a red box
do you so you started the podcast uh
like what why did you start this type of
podcast why do like are you uh well we
wanted to do something really fun and
different yeah and it's a quite a bit of
um
massaging to come up with this idea
because we didn't want to do like a
typical interview style sure sure we
wanted to do something that was a little
bit more curated and we came up with the
first date do you feel yourself an
expert at reading people like no I mean
like are you this is just you know it's
just your own opinion well I don't even
I really have an opinion so the whole
day I mean the whole date is on uh like
a POV of me on a first date with the
celebrity across from me right and so I
have a menu and I have appetizer
questions main course questions and then
dessert question and so I go through the
menu and I ask questions try to find out
what it's like today the other person
wow yeah so can we play it a little bit
now with us or we or or no because then
if we ever go on your show we already
like did your show you know what I mean
the menu changes all the time oh okay
what's an appetizer question
um if you were if it was like you were
on death row and you had one meal that
you could eat what would it be I know
that already what would it be I would
eat a bowl of cereal with a English
muffin with butter and then I would have
a peanut butter and jelly sandwich and I
would have ravioli I can't how many
people pick three meals
I'm about to peace out which cereal
I'm gonna go with Captain Crunch berries
I just you know because it doesn't
matter Health doesn't matter okay yeah
if I was living still maybe I'd go with
like a yeah Special kid gotta go out
with a bank full tummy what about you
um fettuccine alfredo or grilled chicken
God that's so American thank you that's
what I'm from red wine blue uh yeah I I
I think I would what would you do pimp
steak just to stay some kind of fancy
just straight up protein you don't have
to go out with keto on your brain you
know you could carve it up you're about
to die too much yeah
these goggles are so they're so blurry
put that on you can't see you can you
just see like silhouettes of people is
that for skiing or what no whatever you
want it to be no it's for that NBA when
they like win the championship and you
know like the champagne celebrations
they put on those goggles yeah it has an
MBA on the side oh okay oh yeah okay so
so wait so I have a question so so sorry
babe no so but is this an appetizer a
main course
on in your on your podcast like did do
you is it a conversation two-way
conversation yeah oh it is so like I'm
also finding out about like you're
you're kind of like yeah I try to keep
it more pointed towards the guests okay
um and I do like a little bit of a speed
round kind of questions because we're
trying to find out more about the other
person who's judging ultimately if they
are dateable or not me you're the judge
and jury yeah so I call out red flags I
call out green flags we recap them at
the end and then I decide if they're
worthy of a second date or not what's a
green flag a green flag is like when I
asked someone about like what's the key
to a good relationship and then they're
like communication green flag that is
true oh a green flag is a good flag a
green flag is a good flag have you ever
heard of a green flag ever
I never heard someone say oh that was
that was Flags right but that's not fair
okay you gotta have some good going
on I like that I'm gonna go yeah I'm
gonna work around just hand out green
flags now is money a green flag or a red
flag green flag Ron White came on and he
was all about money and I just couldn't
give that guy enough green flags right
money okay okay listen that makes sense
you know you're talking about having
money right having money how is that a
bad thing right it can't well because
here's the thing because if the money
doesn't buy you Freedom what good is the
money some people are on gilded golden
cages because of their money well Ariana
Grande said it best God is a woman
look what did she say it was the thing
about money
smoking a cigarette no wait it was in
her song nine Rings it was uh they say
money can't buy you happiness but you
have never had enough money thank you
next step wait thank you next Davidson
um
thank you next she was whoever said
money can't solve your problems must not
have had enough money to solve them
there you go
I don't know about that quote laughs
that's uh that's not a good look I feel
like money can solve a lot of problems
yeah and if it hasn't solved yours it's
because you don't have enough money
right it can't it can't solve a lot of
it I think money can solve a lot of
problems not all of that but no money
Mo yacht trips okay okay don't you think
Rich guys cheat more
I feel like
if you date a billionaire and he cheats
you just kind of like I'm sorry did you
say close your eyes a billionaire are
you just a billionaire a billionaire
okay you just skipped the first Millions
don't even count it's like not enough
money to cheat these days but if you're
a billionaire it really has gone to that
where if you are a millionaire now in
this country it's like who gives a
every yeah nobody cares which is what I
feel like that's not good no I feel like
that's not good for our economy right
it's like these hats are tight
well it's so funny that you were like if
you date a guy with money she's like
well if you're dating a billionaire and
I'm like wait what no I'm saying a
billionaires billionaires are more
likely to cheat right because they're
like the cream of the crop now
millionaires are a dime a dozen you
can't cheat if you're a millionaire a
girl will go find another Millionaire
right yeah a billionaire oh we are in a
bad bad shape then she didn't realize it
I didn't realize that this was like kind
of what the what about what about this
what about guys with kids
green flag red flag for some it's red
for some it's green I know quite a few
girls that prefer to date guys with kids
so that they don't have to have them
right oh I thought you were gonna go
with because they have senses of
responsibility that no it's just because
they don't want the kids sometimes women
don't want to have kids right sometimes
guys don't want to have kids either yeah
like I mean the things it does to your
body your hormones and it makes you
absolutely psycho have you been on a lot
of bad first dates or good first dates
like do you have on the show or in
general I mean in general that inspired
the show you know like in general like
you have any nightmare stories or first
aid nightmare stories man
I think like the worst first date I ever
went on was with a a guy that was a fan
and I didn't know I didn't know that he
he was like a hardcore fan until like
the end of the date and then I was like
terrified to like I didn't know how to
like admit it at the end yeah he was
like oh I've been following you for like
ever
and I'm like oh yeah really yeah and
online yeah and he just knew like my
jokes and stand-ups
oh yeah I was like I couldn't tell I was
like I'm just gonna get an Uber he's
like I can drive you home I was like
Over My Dead red flag body
yeah that's what he wanted it over your
dead body I think that was like one of
the weird exactly yeah yeah I guess
that's but I think the thing is though
especially with social media and being a
bit of the public eye whomever you date
if you're single they're gonna probably
have at least looked you up and know
something about you yeah that's the
thing you're gonna have to just so
you're gonna have to date someone who's
you're gonna have to probably be with
like an ath like an athlete or like a
country music singer you're gonna have
to be with Chris Stapleton yeah well my
boyfriend owns a barbecue restaurant
like a really famous one oh so you have
a boyfriend I do oh man you're going on
first dates famous barbecue it's a it's
a very famous barbecue restaurant have
you been to Austin lately yeah so you
know Terry blacks yes yes you're dating
Terry black his son okay okay one of
them
right he's a twin we went to I went to
Terry blacks
um uh when I was there last and I
enjoyed it I like the macaroni and
cheese
air to a barbecue Fortune well he
actually started the restaurant he did
Terry black son started the restaurant
there's a lot of family history with
that um but they started the restaurant
and named it after their dad oh okay him
and his brother so what's it like dating
someone who has a twin
it's not that weird he's not an
identical twin oh okay okay but he's
like fraternal it's like everyone
I kind of feel like if you're if you're
a fraternal twin then don't say you're a
twin just say I have a brother yeah
because if you're gonna tell me you're a
tween it better look exactly like you if
not I don't care I don't care what
happened in utero right he needs to look
exactly like you and then this is
something to talk about well let me ask
you this fraternals are two at one two
one fraternal you ready for this splits
splits no that's it's no fraternal
identical
identical hits and then splits into two
eggs no hit it and split it it's
fraternal no identical hits it bang and
then it splits I Dent that's identical
you got the same DNA fraternal I think
you pop two I think you hit two eggs at
the same time with one right two
different sperm results from the
fertilization of two separate eggs so
you hit one no two sperm two eggs that's
insane two sperm two so you just got
pregnant twice yo you pregnant yeah so
you really did just get pregnant twice
crazy I didn't even know that how do you
have two eggs
what do you mean isn't this just one egg
some it depends how you how you drop
them but I tell people just for the most
part dude I'm about to tell you do you
know what's Wild if like if you're when
the woman is pregnant with a girl okay
at like six or seven weeks in utero so
like I'm talking about the the baby is
seven weeks old inside the mom that
fetus already has female fetus already
has all the eggs it will have in its
life or isn't that bizarre how like life
just is like that's the first thing they
set up is like you're gonna have ways to
have more life Wow
um something else so your boyfriend has
a difference was made from a different
sperm than his brother wild yeah okay
and you ready for this sperm can live in
the vaginal walls for like three days so
you could if you you know if you're a
lady who's out there you could get
pregnant by two different men drop in
two different names no have you ever
heard of it
that's insane you're pulling my bees
Google it have you heard of that no
Google it so so you can have so what is
super fungadation twins super super
Foundation twins
woman has intercourse with two different
men in a short period of time while
ovulating it's possible both men and
Pregnant her separately so two different
sperms are they are they and then what
are they that's my question are they
fraternal twins I think they're just
good friends right
foreign
this is my really good friend Bob good
friends yeah oh wow that's cool my dad's
a twin with uh his twin was a woman my
aunt my aunt she passed away but he was
a twin with a woman and he said
fraternal twins but he said when she was
dying she died of a lung disease he felt
like they weren't together but he felt
like he couldn't like really breathe
like he was like I don't know what was
going on that's why yeah and he was like
it's all like connected isn't that wild
I asked I asked Mark the other day if he
ever felt like that and he said no
he said he doesn't have like any like
special Mark black yeah connection to
his brother could it be a super fund
dentation twin then could it be that
maybe you should I don't because he
should be able to feel connected to his
brother I don't know it's possible
I don't know this is Brother good
looking
I got the cute one right okay yeah yeah
the cuter one
he's the stupidest one but he's the
cuter one but you want that's what you
want kidding what this podcast is
sponsored by better help yes look
tell me about I want you to talk to me
about better help I'm going to jump in I
I think that people should know that
they're not alone in what we all relate
to no matter who you are and for me I'm
always going through it relationships my
job down to the littlest decisions I
make I'm someone who is an anxious
person has a little bit you know anxiety
and stuff and I need to get better at
making decisions and you know and one
thing you're always talking about is
practice you always talking about
practice I'm talking about practice all
the time talking about practice all the
time and with even with with with
um uh better help the more you practice
the easier it gets you know because if
you trust yourself to make the decisions
that align with your values like you
always do I do practice makes perfect
and with better help what I like about
it the thing I like most about better
hope no you don't actually physically
have to go to a therapist well that's
the difference because when I started
therapy I was going like to the place
this is so convenient if you are
thinking about it if you've done it
before it's all online you get a
licensed therapist right away it's
designed for that it's designed to
flexible and convenient and suited to
your schedule right so let's get
flexible you're flexible and convenient
and I'm suited to your schedule you are
let therapy be your map with better help
visit betterhelp.com hey babe today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help
help.com hey babe
hello fresh
hi the America's number one meal kid
that's it baby that's what they do it's
the best banish the end of summer Blues
with hello fresh no need to stress about
how you'll handle all this fall because
hello fresh takes care of the meal
planning delivers pre-portioned
ingredients right to your home so
whipping up a homemade meal is a cinch
absolutely and just by chance if you've
been living under a rock and you know
what hellofresh is it is what happens is
you get farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep you
skip trips to the grocery store you kind
of hollow fresh to make home cooking
easy fun affordable and that's why I
said it that's why it is America's
number one meal now listen parents we
got enough back to school shopping and
planning to I mean I'm up to my eyeballs
and back to school shopping I know it
it's all I do so I let hellofresh get
the groceries I saved cash with the
pre-portioned meals right to my door and
the family loved it the kids loved it
and I was able to get them their back to
school supplies that they desperately
needed I got them a bunch of pencil
cases I love it I do I feel like an
adult that is using technology to it's
like yes I I like participating in
hellofresh it makes me feel like I'm
part of a community and like I'm oh I'm
an adult yeah I'm getting these these
meals delivered to my home yeah recipes
kind of cook a recipe no yeah no it's
it's awesome and then my kids play in
the boxes they've got a nice big fun
green bottle you know uh beige boxes
with green lettering right now if you go
to hellofresh.com slash 50 hey babe and
use the code 5-0 hey babe you get 50 off
plus free shipping what is it tell them
one more time hellofresh.com five zero
hey babe and then use that same code
five zero Hey bid you get 50 off plus
free shipping
again it's America's number one meal
hello fresh baby
what's up everybody I am on the road
right now just announced a lot of dates
for my tour they're on sale right now
you can get tickets at salvolcano
comedy.com I'm coming to Bowling Green
Cincinnati Toledo Wilkes-Barre
Wilmington Macon Savannah and Athens
Georgia uh I'm coming to Peoria Rockford
and Springfield Illinois Cedar Rapids
Duluth Appleton Rochester Davenport and
Elkhart Indiana gearing up to film my
special in Chicago uh in December tune
in next week I will give all the
information about the special taping but
until then Savile County comedy.com and
I'll see you guys on the road what's up
everybody I'm so excited I'm back on the
road after three months off now's your
time to come see my new hour that I'm
doing I'm proud of it we're gonna film
it as a special this year this weekend I
am in Atlantic City New Jersey
and then in September I am in Los
Angeles Portland Seattle
Las Vegas New York City we got some
tickets left for the theater at Madison
Square Garden September 23rd and then in
October we're in Nebraska we're in uh uh
uh um what's the other state Missouri
Kansas City St Louis Hammond Indiana
we're coming all over and then we got
November December January February dates
christycomedy.com really proud of this
new hour now's your time to come see it
Go by the tiki wikis baby yes
and let's talk to them about merch real
quick real quick ready let's talk about
merch baby let's talk about you and me
me all the hair
on your body
look about merch wow wow oh my God
blacked out yeah
just re-upped on some Merch this isn't
it but yeah
but that is shout out Prince Paul is
wearing blackface
but yeah guys check out wait how do we
where do they get merch
nope Z kid doesn't get easier than that
no press.com go get the merch
I don't know man I don't know that I
would uh would you want a twin would you
want an identical twin no I like the
Fraternal fraternal is better yeah yeah
I don't know I mean it's such a unique
experience I'm sure if it happened to me
you don't want to I mean I'm sure every
I'm sure every twin who has an identical
is very thankful and loves it my thing
is like raising kids like you know I
have little kids it's like to think
about getting my say two-year-old now
down for a nap and get her through her
bath uh bedtime routine or whatever to
then have to do that twice or to then to
have the second you get one down and you
get one to sleep and do what you want
and then the second one doesn't want to
do it and then upsets the other one your
life must just be like a constant cycle
of what the how do I get through
this yeah you have to be really touching
like complaining to someone and then
they're like yeah I have triplets so how
old are your kids
of uh a 13 year old stepson
eight-year-old daughter and a
two-year-old daughter wow so I got yeah
which one's your favorite
my favorite
you know I know that this is like a
changes I don't know if there's a
cop-out answer I don't I don't know that
I have a favorite but I will tell you
just honestly I'm so much more connected
to my eight-year-old because she was my
first like my first biological child and
I was like I read my like my life it was
the only time in my life where like
truly my life for those moments when she
was being born like was like in slow
motion like when somebody like I was
like I remember almost every second
the parameters of time changed I was
like oh my God like I like that
and I couldn't believe it that I was
like this is my baby and like and just
boom connected where you know and it was
amazing and I love my two-year-old just
like I love my eight-year-old but like I
don't even remember her being born I
mean I remember her being born but but I
think that like I was like you know and
you're an only child yeah I am yeah so
um not my choice did you ever feel like
did you feel like I I would have rather
did you were you fine with it like
growing up did you even notice that
you'd have it like siblings or did you
missed the sibling not being there no
but you don't know anybody I mean I grew
up in my family my cousin lived
downstairs to me so she was like a
sister but but I know I knew that I did
not want my children to be only children
I was like I I knew it'd be so much
better if they had siblings because
there were times where I was like this
you know I'm just an only child it's
almost like embarrassing sometimes where
I'm like I don't have yeah my parents
[Laughter]
I actually hate telling people on middle
not hate it but I used to be embarrassed
by it so I would being so embarrassed by
telling people that I was actually an
only child I swear to God where I was
like 14 15 I would tell people I was one
of ten
[Laughter]
yeah it's like one was like what are
their names and I was like oh boy oh
yeah did you rattle off you just rattled
off yeah are you ready ready I rattled
off ten of the two all right what are
the other taking bets right now don't
think ahead I'm gonna ask him to name
nine means in a row without stammering
what are the odds he's gonna do it can
he pull this Bluff off yeah you can do
it I'm one of nine you oh you're one no
I'm one of no I'm sorry I'm one of ten
you're one of ten I have nine brothers
and sisters oh how many brothers and
sisters I have I have nine brothers and
sisters but how many brothers and how
many sisters oh I have I have four I
have four brothers and Five Sisters okay
what are their names
Sal Mike Joe Phoenix are the four boys
and then the five girls are Lauren
Venetia Jasmine Delilah Violet and Susan
those are the people sitting around you
you didn't say there was no there was no
you didn't give me anything Phoenix come
from I know all right fine Sal Joe Mike
and feed all right fine like that was
the one I was in my drug test I can't
use their names I got four brothers and
Five Sisters Brian Michael Leonardo
Jeffrey are my brother sure and then my
sister's are Magdalena Mariana Mary Lou
Lynn and Eileen
she's one of five she's got four sisters
and one brother all the sisters names
Maria is their middle name everything is
Marie Marie Marie that's interesting you
got siblings no I'm an only child there
you go what was it like for you growing
up did you feel like you missed out on
siblings or was like you didn't even
think of it it was only one time in my
life where I really wanted a sibling and
I asked my mom if I could have a brother
or a sister and she said no you went out
we're the trans version of each other
yeah you're me as a guy I'm you as a
woman
okay it's very interesting
so give us give us some more of these
these questions that you would ask let
me see yeah those were appetizer
questions yeah
um more of a main course question would
be like uh how do you feel about hygiene
like if we go on a date with a girl and
she doesn't shave her armpits or her
legs like not necessarily like a Bo
smell but how do you how do you feel
about that I don't mind hair as much as
I mind
um
us I think a smell would be worse than
hair for me I can deal with I can deal
with hair because I don't have that much
hair I'm like more of a hairless man
that's you know and it's a problematic I
don't grow hair so if the woman grow
hair I would be like that's balanced
yeah but I smell I try to bathe myself I
don't like trying to smell I try yeah
what would you do so I need 100 a plus
hygiene in all facts
so I'm not nothing against people you
know but I for me for my personal
preference
I mean it's got to be like the the tip
tip tip Tip Top hygiene
I'll ask you another question how do you
tell your girlfriend that she that she's
getting fat
I probably don't
you don't I would say yeah I would I
wouldn't phrase it like that of course
not I mean if you're honest yeah let's
say she's like really sort of
getting a little clumping up it's like a
little too much I'm not above that right
but if I'm not and she's and I want to
say to her because I'm concerned right
because it's a health thing right or
maybe she's like I don't want to see her
is that what you mean like maybe you're
losing some attraction you're like oh
man oh wow
um you find yourself looking at
other girls and you're like honestly to
be honest with you in my current
situation I would tell one of the kids
to say it
that's what I would do I would I would
say I'll give you I'll buy you like
Nutella I'll give you unlimited Nutella
till September if you just whisper in
mommy's here that she's getting a little
fat and you don't want to lose Mommy and
um I'll write something down for you and
you can like I would have one of the
kids say it and then also it's a good
test because I would know then if one of
my kids which ones if that and which one
will just is loyal to this goddamn
family right like I am right so you'll
have the kids
yes I think that's the best way to do it
but if you don't have it's very
difficult I think to tell a woman like
oh you know I'm thinking about like
getting into shape myself and I'm going
to start going to the gym and eating
better we should do it together it was
something like that there you go yeah
that's good joint effort thing yeah put
yourself in the same boat maybe yeah
yeah you know I mean do people on your
show ever used to be like I would just
be like look you're getting fat are they
blunt like that
um I've had two people say that they
would just break up
is that a red flag or a green I think
that's I mean there's how do you judge
there's no right answer to that question
it's just more of an entertaining one
for me I want to say how would you tell
your partner if they were getting fat
well I like fat dudes okay I like a
belly I like a guy to be a little bit
like thicker than me you know just right
okay is your boyfriend fat he's not fat
but he has a belly he's not fat at all
okay but he's got he's got a good smelly
belly yeah I know all about it oh yeah
good he's lost 30 pounds Sal what would
you congratulations
would you tell him he was getting too
skinny
[Laughter]
do me a favor order me a pizza yeah
too skinny I don't know I'd be worried
like are you do you have cancer
good question how would you receive it
if someone of one of your partners told
you that that I was getting too skinny
no too fat your original question
um I I think that I would be like I
really appreciate the honesty
and this is the end of our relationship
okay
I will say this no I'm just kidding I
will say that here's the thing what I
will say about relationships is I do
feel like my friends who don't have
children who are in relationships they
don't want to be in it's mind-blowing to
me why you would stay if you don't have
kids as you're an adult younger women in
our 20s I get it you like sometimes that
confrontation but when you get older I'm
like what in what world would you be
unhappy with someone for like one day
more than you need to be if you don't
have children I I but I guess only me
having kids I would know that like
there's no reason then just go live your
life you'll get over it the chemicals
you'll pee out the chemicals for that
person in 21 days well not just drink
water also impossible to not know you're
gaining weight like you know that you're
outgrowing your shorts and right crazy
outfit that well so I mean someone
telling you what you already know is
probably just I would I think in a part
of me it would be really helpful if
someone was like
like you could maybe go on a diet or
something I don't know that'd be a
horrible way to say it is the issue I'm
having yeah I'd appreciate it in like a
weird
I really needed you to
kind of slit my throat for me to like
stab you that's one way to lose weight
bleed out you bleed out Bleed It Out
well let me ask you this my instinct
when you said how do you stay with
someone for more than a day right I
would say it's really hard to have that
kind of conversation sometimes that
breakup conversation like I've I've got
to rip off a Band-Aid babe so let me ask
you a question
is this how many times are the main
course this is probably like this is
going to be in a moose Bush okay yeah uh
how many people if you could think back
people you've broken up with or people
have broken up with you
has it been difficult have you always
done it immediately has one resonate
with you did anyone dump you in a
horrible way what was your worst breakup
like you know what I mean like it's it's
I've had to have that conversation a
couple times and it's brutal I think
when you're younger you're just you know
you haven't lived life as much now
if you were to get broken up with I mean
you just understand like you've been
through that so it's like the pain you
know the pain is going to go away it'll
just suck for a minute or two and I feel
like I'm at a point now like as you get
older where you just I've accepted like
not everybody's gonna like you like not
everyone's gonna always like you so but
if you're dating someone it's good for a
while and then you come to the point
where you have to do it in a nice way I
don't think you want to be hurtful to
someone but you can't stay in it because
you can't do something like that for
somebody else right right it's it's not
easy yeah you remember that Dean Cook
joke from like 20 years ago where he's
like like people stay in relationships
for stupid reasons like they can make
excuses she's like I would break up with
my CDs are in his truck
yeah yeah yeah I I don't know it's hard
I I I think um
I don't know now I honestly if I was
ever single again I don't think that I
would care as much like breaking like I
was just like I got my kids like I I I
would be able to break up or get broken
up with and deal with it in stride
better yeah but watch me kill myself the
next relationship just on
on with the direct energy weapon have
you had any tough breakups on either end
the hardest breakup I had uh was with a
guy that I dated for a year over covid
and I didn't like him at all okay
because
[Laughter]
so that would have been a great nickname
yeah
um I liked him in the beginning but I
was never in love but it was coveted and
I didn't really want to be alone I was
one of those pieces of that I was
like well being with you is better than
being alone but then I reached a point
where I was like I think being with you
actually sucks like more than being
alone yeah
she was he wrote in a journal hey guys
today we're here with a sponsor for your
bouncing bundle of joy you can have a
kid talking about my balls ah no we're
not talking about a baby we're talking
about your baby makers that's right
today's show is brought to you by
manscapes but just like babies you
delicate little guys have sensitive skin
and dessert products that are only skin
safe yep not only but made with safe
ingredients that's where manscapes
Platinum package comes in from razors to
shower care this package goes above the
gold standard for your body hair so
treat your beautiful boys to the world's
finest toys at manscape.com and use our
code hey babe for 20 off plus free
shipping dude a couple things manscapes
so I I use it all my friends use it I
love this Platinum package that you
spoke about but also the lawnmower 4.0
body trimmer that's amazing and the weed
whacker the weed whacker you can trim
your nose hairs and the little hairs
that just you know like Little Sprouts
just shoot off your nuts you can you can
UK that are so hard to get if you try to
get there with a razor you're gonna
you're gonna Nick your nuts you're in
for a wild adventure we got a bleeder
the weed whacker knows an ear hair
trimmer feature they feature this
proprietary proprietary Advanced Skin
safe technology to protect your delicate
parts and holes I I get here I get hairs
on my ears nose and nuts I use that weed
whacker I never ears nose and nuts no
they're not head and shoulders
I love the the lawnmower because it has
a light on it which I don't know like
that you might not think that's a big
thing but I've had Shavers in the past
and yeah light on it it just no it
really does help I really like it it's
awesome it's a little charging station
right by my toothbrush and it's ready
same with me and then I like this they
got the aluminum Free Ultra Premium
deodorant for the cologne quality scent
on the go it's basically a deodorant for
you nuts it's it's it's amazing get 20
off in free shipping with code hey babe
at manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use code
hey babe use the Platinum package
because the gold standard is no longer
good enough
yes
um I don't really like your spiritual
journey like you're like just sitting
there like crying like yourself in like
a little stupid page and I was like I
don't know I could not stand this guy oh
yeah so he encouraged me to write in a
journal and I was like okay I will and I
wrote a list of things I liked about him
and a list of things I didn't like about
him and the things I liked about him
there was four I liked his eye color
I like the fact that he was a man he had
a penis right he had okay ABS right and
I don't like that you don't like okay
ABS that's why they were like I mean it
just seriously he was like ripped so you
don't like that he was a pro athlete and
he just sucked and so um for his actual
team did he suck too no he was he was
like a skier or something oh or
something yeah he's I just did not give
a about this guy so much he never
even cared he was also like a pro
mountain biker or something and I was
like he was always
a loser yeah and so he ended up
uh usually the people that reached it
and then the list of things I didn't
like about this yeah the fourth thing
about him yeah I don't even remember oh
it was that he was an athlete I thought
his job was kind of cool okay and then
the things that I didn't like about him
went on and on and he thought it was
cool it was maybe a skier
and then things that went on and on
pages and so I left one day to go to the
grocery store and he read my journal and
he saw that red flag
that's what I said yeah and he I came
home and he was just in a little ball
fetus position just bawling his little
eyes out and he was like oh my God I
found out all these things you don't
like about me and I was like I guess
this is the best way for me to let you
know I don't like you right and then you
just left wow and then three days later
he moved out right Wow
since yeah because covet I mean I didn't
want to be alone the whole reason I was
with him is because I didn't want to be
alone how quick did you move in together
uh uh it only a couple months in wow
that's that's made a move it's typical
for me right let's try your red flag on
my back have you have you lived with
many people
um I was married
I lived with
um I was married for five years okay
um and then that guy and I live with my
boyfriend now that's it three okay I've
had a really long relationships oh no
there was another guy that I lived with
too right
and you don't want kids I would love
kids but just not now I'd love them
right now right really oh yeah all right
does your are you trying harder now no I
want to get married first okay but as
soon as we get married I'd love to have
kids see that's cool because you got
married got divorced from now you're
like I'm ready to get I'll get married
again that's nice you believe you
believe in it I do believe in it yeah
I'm very monogamous too and I love my
boyfriend a lot so I keep out I had a
picture of a diamond ring on the
background on my phone he likes to play
games on my phone he won't download them
on his phone because he gets too
addicted to him so he just plays them on
mine I feel like this is one of those
episodes your boyfriend's listening to
putting the gun in and out
she's talking about the skier guy that
I'm embarrassed gun in he's just like
keeps I love to get a live shot of him
right now
what is very monogamous
yeah cause that's like um like redundant
right just
some people like don't like I don't
cheat there's no but that's monogamous
bar monogamous and they still cheat
the Only Rule is to not yeah
that's kind of monogamous like kind of a
skier no no it's actually beautiful yeah
yeah it's like yeah I've been married
for seven years
right a slip up then I
don't know it's over yeah yeah you can't
really go back yeah right you can go
back to being monogamous but for like a
very short amount of time so you oh okay
so that's what you mean by very
monogamous meaning you won't even
because you're saying like like for
example okay you know what she's
actually making me think of something I
have a friend who prove it allegedly
allegedly I have a friend who
who she
has cheated on her husband twice in 10
years okay he's cheated on her too but
they have a rule where they are allowed
have given each other they do that no
where they said they were allowed to
have three times throughout their
marriage where they cheat and if it
becomes more than that like three
encounters not three different people
like if they they were allowed to be
like anything more than that like they
wanted to like experiment with it
anything more than that they would get
divorced and more than three as far as I
know the girls that too and the guy's at
one I I don't know I don't know but he's
got a kid if he doesn't cash in before
she hits three then it's gonna cancel it
out before he even got to well no and
then they would just they and they would
do they were saying that if it was
anything more than three or multiple
times with the same person then they
have to stop okay but a one a random
like you know if you hook up with the
somebody on like vacation they that they
don't want to count that but you are you
into the whole past thing like he's
saying no no very monogamy
what about you Sal are you monogamous
yes oh yeah yeah very even argument very
monogamous
yeah no yeah I think I've always been
I don't know yeah just uh
if I'm in a relationship I'm I'm into
the person yeah so it's like it's not
even a really too much of a thought you
know but uh if I'm casually dating I
don't think you need to casually dating
yeah you're not very monogamous okay but
let me ask you this uh because as an
adult right like what do you have to
have a conversation with someone say
you're my girlfriend now I'm your
boyfriend like do we have like how as
kids we would do that but how do you
establish
it's just you and I do you have to have
a calm I don't know I've been out of the
game I've like a people I still
have to have that do you literally say
do you want to be my boyfriend I don't
ever ask that okay so how does it come
so how did you know that Harry black son
was your boyfriend right because
what's his name Mike black Terry black
son is a fraternal twin what's his name
mark Mike is his brother Mark and Mike
Black Market Mike black nice well I
guess
for him
I never had the conversation we just
never ever separated from day one and it
became like a it just wasn't just yeah
you could kind of now what are you gonna
do what are you gonna do if you find out
Mark black is journaling
hide it
okay just go into the closet and write
in your Journal but you did do the
journal I only did I
[Laughter]
expected a trap for him to find that's
the only reason you didn't find it
really and I was just like you want but
isn't that a isn't that like a tough way
to let to let him know like to see reads
a list of everything you need to go down
like that but why because he just didn't
get it any other way like it was very
obvious that I wasn't very into him okay
he just
you wouldn't be able to tell him hey
this is not working see that's the
problem is that I couldn't do it and I
would have conversations with my friends
and my mom and I'm like how do I leave
this guy why couldn't you do it though
because it takes balls and I didn't have
balls but you left the surgery you wrote
scripture about how much you hate him
yeah and then you left that open that
seems like it would be harder on purpose
subconscious yeah I was hoping that he
would read it because that would have
been the easiest out for me and it was
and it was easy to this day does he know
that you you that was a setup I'm sure
he just found out oh wow you heard it
here first that's a breakup exclusive
reliving his nightmare of a past with me
it wasn't fun yeah wow and all during
covid too yeah he's homeless on Sixth
Street during covet there wasn't no okay
I went through covet for me I went
through going through covid with kids
was is different like going through like
a lot of people experience a lot a lot
of people had like the best times of
their life during covert because people
Miss covet despite the insane stress and
the worry about my family and here on
news if you had to look for a silver
lining I got to spend that's
unprecedented what happened in our
lifetime maybe not happen again right so
I get it especially if I had would have
kids doing that you get to be with your
kids well that's why so many people
don't go haven't went back to work
because there's work but they're like I
had a spiritual awakening why am I
working all day I could spend time with
my family and friends that I love Sal do
you have kids no no but I want them okay
I wanna I'm gonna put a baby in you boy
how many kids I'd like four
four why four name them I love kids
Matthew Mark Luke and John there you go
um
I don't know four sounds good I like a
big family yeah I have three sisters
okay are you the only boy yeah wow yeah
I like a big family so
um I just feel like the more the merrier
you know I want three I want an oddball
right you want like a one kid who said I
want one kid who like they don't like
and then I be friend right yeah like
she's an outcast yeah she here she's
okay so the kids yeah so what are you
waiting for then when people say you
want kids right now but you're just like
I feel like life's going by every day
it's ticking by yeah I know I know I
tell my boyfriend the same thing
so your hope is that two of your
children dislike your other child okay
and then I come in like the hero right
right and
on parent that child and just what about
you boy girl what's your ratio boy girl
them right right that's true right no
one likes them they're not even popular
right you are smarter no here's the
question though now the other two hear
you say that they won't I'm smarter than
them they're the idiots remember maybe
leaving the journal let them know in the
journey
that's what I was gonna say but if
you're Oddball Kid journals
yeah what if your son comes out to you
by sliding the journal to you
Mom I got to tell you something read
chapters one through four there right
there
I mean you're a big fan of slipping
notes yes to your children having them
relay messages yes I think well my kids
my I do have what my middle daughter is
is gonna be the one who she's very um
she's got a lot of energy she gets
yelled at a lot by you know other
parents teachers not other parents but
how do you feel about that she's loud
here's the thing here's here my style of
parenting my girl style of parenting how
we parent our kids is very much like
it's like business Chic is what he calls
it business Chic is where like look if
you know you like as soon as you leave
this house first of all we only started
letting her go on play dates outside the
house very recently we're like going to
be respectful you be nice but if you
feel even an adult someone's crossing
the line and yelling at you and whatever
and going to like you defend yourself
that's why you have you in Jiu Jitsu
yeah you defend yourself and then you
tell Mommy and Daddy really Mommy and
then Mommy will go over there and take
care of it yeah and you're gonna get
cold like hello yeah yeah uh my daughter
took a juice box from your daughter and
she put her in a Kimora lock yeah yeah
yeah what's going on over there are you
are you raising them business Chic yeah
my no my kid I think listen parenting
you just feel like you're making a
critical mistake like every day you're
it's like that I think Louis CK or
somebody had a bit where they're like
you know you say something telling me
reprimand them once you're like oh
irreparable damage for life and you feel
that way as a parent when you're like
but I have to like yell at them and
intervene right now but I also don't
want to stifle their creativity right
and I want them to express who they are
and then you're like but I can't let my
kid you know I can't let my kid call
another kid sucker at the park which is
what she did so I'm like I can't she my
kid fully called another child and she
screamed about some kid going down the
slide
for that no a full word that she said
the word full
sure
he
can't cut her off that they were all
waiting to go down a slide and some
little kid okay I swear to God push past
her and went down this side she goes you
and then she came down the slide after
him and they didn't me and we just saw
her yelled at him we were like oh we
were there was at a birthday party so
how did you explain that to everybody
well she I don't know nobody said
anything we re because it was like it
was like in an indoor um you know like
trampoline park type thing so she called
her and we kind of just moved on me and
her mama just you know man up with the
worst curses like you know yeah but the
problem is it's a fun word it is fun
well that's why I stopped doing the pot
we used to do a podcast from my house
but I stopped doing it because I was
like she can hear you know you get lost
when you're on a podcast you're yelling
about stuff and whatever and I was in
the house last night I felt so bad every
time I know my daughter came downstairs
cursing up the storm this morning she's
like what the were you guys doing
last time
are you smoking weed
and weeds where's my Cheerios I'm like
Sally ate them he was high
yeah I I don't know man
okay that that's a good main quartz
question what's a dessert question
um
what is the sweetest thing you've ever
done for your significant other
oh Jesus the sweetest the sweetest thing
you've ever done for someone for someone
that you were dating
uh it sounds hard to recollect no I mean
not because not because I can't think of
one because like isn't that what you are
romantic from a place you operate from
nine minutes all the time there's a lot
of people that aren't that romantic I
don't leave like
a rose in the fridge should chiffon find
or anything like that yeah
Ron White said the sweetest thing he
ever did was put someone on his
insurance okay yeah there you go
that's very nice that was super nice
I've never had anyone put me on their
insurance
I've you know what I've done I've but
again see this see now like I'm I'm
gonna I'm gonna go I'm immediately
buying flowers and putting my girl on my
insurance after this yeah but uh because
I'm realizing now like most of the I
guess what you would consider sweet
things they're for my daughters like I
will
like send my daughters cards telling
them how much I love them and like put
them like I'll mail them to my house and
it'll be like mail from them but it's
just me saying how much I love like
randomly like no birthday nothing like
just I love you and I my daughter has
them like I think that's great I think
and then or like I have this little
thing I got my eight-year-old where it's
like I can text it because she doesn't
have a phone I can text it and it's this
thing it has it's got a big heart on it
and it'll like make like these circles
and the Heart Will spin when I send it a
message and it'll be like I love you
like Daddy thing whereas where their mom
now like my girl like yeah I don't
I get I take her um I got her a pedicure
um
I what have I done
Puerto Rico she's from Puerto Rico I
took her to Puerto Rico that was nice a
trip is Italy I took her to Italy Italy
Puerto Rico yes Venetia knows she's
planned it
um so um um um what questions are I mean
but I'm talking about something that's
like
simple
have you ever done the rose petals like
no she's allergic candles
um romantic evenings
surprise birthday parties I've done for
her that's sweet there you go she's
online too I've done that I've done that
and she's on my insurance as well she's
on my insurance to that so but what is
what's nice thing they've been doing
yeah can you have an example I'm asking
for a friend
I'm super romantic and I I love doing
things for people that I'm with
I don't know what the sweetest thing
I've ever
oh actually
for
um
one time
my significant other came home and I was
laying on the table no it was my
ex-husband back in his mouth here we go
really sweet stuff
thing I ever did was when I was married
right and maybe if you marry me I'll do
something extra special for you too but
when I was married I was laying on the
kitchen table naked and I had uh that's
so sweet thank you very nice I thought
that was already a grand gesture and I
had um those big leaves all over me and
I had sushi based all over my body and
then I had I had sewn together black
curtains so when he came home he had to
like move the curtains out of the way
and like it was like a whole set like a
whole scene and I had all of this like
sake and I had like everything set up
and so he sat at the table and ate
dinner off of me and then I would just
feed myself as I got hungry okay okay
who placed all the sushi on you I did
okay yeah I was just laying there and I
was just like he had no clue about that
no he didn't know it he just came home
for Valentine's Day and I was just laid
out on the table okay and did he return
that favor he was very romantic too okay
all the way up until the day he cheated
on me there it is he wasn't very
monogamous Maybe you next time you think
before he cheats
did you when you found out he cheated on
you were you like relieved like I can
get out of this man after you were
shocked no I was happy about it that was
his journal at the yeah yeah at the end
of the marriage I was pretty unhappy
right and so when he cheated on me
because I never would have left right
because I was like I was married and I
was like you know do you hate him now or
are you no time I hated him for two
years but now you're like you could see
him and it doesn't matter yeah you're
fine you could see him with the girl he
cheated on you with it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter at all I even gave him
money to start a restaurant really
wow did the restaurant do well it's
doing great wait wait
he cheated on you you got divorced and
then you funded his business cheating on
me was the best thing he opened up a
sushi restaurant
did he no oh
it was an Italian restaurant okay wow
and you so you were part owner or an
investor oh okay
is he a chef no he's he's just the
manager of the restaurant but he's named
Joe deroza no okay I just had him on my
show though Joe's not monogamous
you cheat and pig piece of it is
yes
love Joe but he's never even lived with
a girl yeah no well yeah he's got too
many video games
look at this dying wife ass husband can
I have sex with my ex One Last Time
wow what a loser why not no but the wife
no the wife asked the husband the wife
is dying at that point just let her
cheat don't tell ask him why does he
think you're on the way out you're gonna
leave him with that forever just go do
it if you had to do it don't ask him can
I sleep in my ex one last time yeah no
I guess that she's thinking she was
thinking like this is the right thing to
do is to ask my husband before even
though I'm dying the wife is dying I
want to be right by him
she had sex with the ex you're him she
asks you she's dying
what do you do what do you say how do
you handle that
um I think I would be like look I don't
I mean you really put me on the spot
here like I know you're gonna die but
like
why would you do this to me I don't want
to make it about me but like I would
how's I I would say I would say yeah I
would say do you I'd say you know what
go ahead do it see you in hell
I would do it I ought
and then do you want to tell you if any
woman I was ever with came to me and was
like can I
cheat and have sex with someone else I
would I've never from the beginning
cared about that I don't know why I've
cared about other things but I don't
know why for me if you cheated on me I
like almost don't take it personal like
it doesn't affect my ego at all I don't
know why other things do but not that
yeah like when guys go nuts like you
cheated on me like like if you
if my girlfriend was out till four
o'clock in the morning I hadn't heard
from her the last thing I'd be thinking
is she's with another guy and if she was
with another guy I would almost be
relieved because I'd be like oh she's
not dead all my head my I'm like a
mother like I would be like if you don't
text me back in an hour I think it's
because you something's horrific is
happening or dead you're on drugs you
got hit by a bus I would never think
it's because you're sucking another
guy's right I would never think
that right which is weird show because
most guys yes most guys would think that
right like you would think if you didn't
hear from your girlfriend for hours no
I'm not saying this currently but in
your life I'm saying I think that would
be the natural yeah but see me it's like
automatically like I think they're she's
dead you mean like four in the morning
she's out and you know I would think
she's I mean first they're just worried
about it my first thing he wouldn't be
like is she out cheating right I would
be working with LSG okay but I don't
know I just I mean I would it would
bother me if someone cheated I mean like
you would take it personal
I'm pretty sure pretty much yeah I think
it's I don't think maybe I don't think
it's a pretty personal thing I think
that's what it is I don't get because
it's not even an ego thing it's like
what what's going on what's the respect
like yeah you know like yeah for me I
don't know for me I'm just like there's
so many people in the like just whatever
there's a lot of people in the world hey
Bill yeah eight billion of them I don't
know Mark Jeff bases were 163 Million
worth 163 billion dollars they're
getting that point one in there one
point one is a hundred million right
that point one is 100.1 is 100 million
Jeff Bezos billionaire
yeah there you go so the green flag I've
never dated a billionaire
uh but you date exclusively I'm sure
millionaires
right who made you make sure of that how
do you vet that
um
I bet that like when I met Mark I
thought he was a busboy
I met him at the restaurant he delivered
the food I was like oh thank you and
then he sat down with us and I was like
what are you doing
right and then I went on a date with him
but you knew he was the owner when you
went on the date no he didn't yeah I
didn't know that he was he owned the
restaurant for days yeah okay so you
gave them when you thought he was a
busboy yeah but he was like a really hot
bus boy okay so I was like I like this
right yeah so I actually don't vet that
but I think
but then I saw his lake house so then
you knew here
and he's like you know how many dishes
but it's his money it's not family money
it's his money he was like you know how
many dishes he earned it yeah he's
earned it I earned it I like that yeah
he's a hard worker because I know you're
born people are born into circumstance
and I understand that but sometimes when
somebody's like oh I'm wealthy I'm like
your parents were you didn't do anything
he grew up super poor right from like a
little Old Town in Texas those poor
blacks
it's been hey babe
wait what should we well she plugs up in
the beginning do you want anything else
to plug like anything uh follow the
first day show that's it follow it you
can find me at I am Lauren Compton on
everything
okay cool well thank you so much for
joining us yeah appreciate it thank you
what a great first day great that was a
great version I can't wait for the
second one oh we get a second one green
flags hey babe got green flagged now
have fun you journaling homos
get merch you just start a new merch get
it we make those t-shirts
that could be your merch
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey babe